bien mes chers amis pardon de ces
quelques minutes de retard
euh d'habitude
je j'assume la responsabilité de vous
présenter l'orateur aujourd'hui ça ne
sera pas la
peine parce que vous connaissez tous
très bien Alain Lambert et je n'aurais
donc pas besoin de vous
rappeler ses responsabilités politiques
successives à la mairie d'Alançon au
Sénat à la présidence du Conseil général
de l'Orne puis au gouvernement de 2002 à
2004 comme ministre du Budget où il
assume la lutte le le contre le déficit
et je n'aurais pas besoin de vous
rappeler encore moins le rôle qu'il a
joué dans notre équipe j'allais dire
dans notre amitié dans notre euh dans
la la solidarité que nous avons vécu
ensemble toutes ces dernières années il
a joué dans la
préparation des campagnes
présidentielles un rôle très important
parce qu'il a été auprès de moi celui
qui au fond a pensé la stratégie de
lutte contre le
déficit et la dette et euh euh euh j'ai
euh pour ma part en tout cas trouvé dans
sa réflexion euh les les ressources
principales de notre projet sur ce sujet
donc c'est quelqu'un
euh dont le le le parcours politique est
évidemment pour nous euh extrêmement
précieux donc euh euh Jean-Pierre rillou
va vous en dire un mot vous allez
l'écouter je n'ai pas besoin de rappeler
il le sait que ce qu'il a la foule qu'il
a devant lui ça n'est que la partie
émergé de d'un iceberg beaucoup plus
volumineux puisque c'est par Internet
principalement que ces
conférences qui deviennent presque
hebdomadaires sont diffusées je veux
simplement vous dire un
mot de ce qu'on ne voit
pas dans la personnalité de alinambert
c'est pas seulement un responsable
politique c'est quelqu'un qui a la
générosité
de animer des groupes et la générosité
plus importante encore de
penser des solutions réelles et pas
seulement des mots pour les communautés
dont il a la charge il a alors je ne
sais pas si c'est son son enracinement
notarial mais il a puisque vous savez il
a été le président et le principal
animateur des Notaires de
France il a une manière de
penser qui est à la
fois très originale très pratique et
très sensible et pour moi c'est une
chose
infiniment
précieuse il
a au fond ses antennes pour essayer de
faire que la politique ne reste pas dans
les mots dans les phrases dans les
périodes mais qu'elle entre dans la
réalité et et comme j'aime beaucoup ça
c'est une manière pour moi de lui
exprimer ma gratitude alors le travail
qu'il a fait dont il va vous dire enfin
vous rendre compte c'est un travail et
Dieu sait qu'on y est attaché dans cette
maison contre la prolifération
perpétuelle de tout ce qui est les
contraintes administratives les
contrôles et les normes dont notre
pauvre pays souffre perpétuellement
comme si alors il y a eu des ouvrages
célèbres écrits sur ce sujet comme si le
travail
principal des
administrations euh est un travail euh
est un travail au fond de de de
perpétuelle
multiplication euh des règlements et des
normes alors il a fait une œuvre très
euh profonde du point de vue de la
l'analyse et de la réflexion mais il a
fait quelque chose qu'on ne fait jamais
il y a mis de l'humour euh de de la
drôlerie de même quelquefois du rire aux
éclats et dans un rapport
administratif c'est rare et donc c'est
une autre raison de lui dire notre
gratitude Jean-Pierre Riou va dire un
mot et après c'est Alain Lambert qui
va non c'est c'est un simple mot de
remerciement nous sommes très honorés
monsieur le ministre que vous ayez bien
voulu participer à ces ces rendez-vous
du de la
démocratie je saisis l'occasion pour
vous dire que c'est l'avant-dernière
séance nous aurons la la dernière séance
le 18 juin avec une jeune et
brillantissime philosophe Corine péuchon
qui s'intéresse depuis très
longtemps à la question de au fond
l'éthique de la de la vulnérabilité
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en
démocratie à la fois l'enregistrement
des des questions bioéthiques qui nous
qui nous transpersent tous aujourd'hui
et comment on peut essayer d'élaborer à
partir de cela une sorte de philosophie
du sujet du sujet souffrant du sujet
vulnérable du sujet à à à hausser à sa
hauteur de d'homme ou de femme en terme
plus démocratique qu'aujourd'hui et donc
c'est ce sera je crois une séance
importante sur des sujets que nous avons
trop rarement abordé depuis depuis
quelques années euh l'inflation
normative je je la subis comme vous tous
n'est-ce pas et donc je n'ai pas la
moindre idée pour l'instant sur ce que
peut être la lutte contre l'inflation
normative mais monsieur le ministre vous
vous allez nous éclairer merci puisque
Jean-Pierre vient de vous donner une
partie du programme je veux vous dire ou
vous rappeler parce que vous avez déjà
reçu une première annonce que le samedi
22 juin oui nous aurons une réflexion à
la suite du Conseil national qui a lieu
le matin l'après-midi le Parti démocrate
européen
euh que je copréside avec avec Francesco
Rutelli et que nous avons créé avec
Romano pri organise une le premier forum
du renouveau européen comme vous voyez
c'est le coup d'envoi de notre réflexion
en vue de la campagne des européennes du
printemps prochain et nous accueillerons
deux invités l'un sera Michel
Barnier commissaire européen et l'autre
sera guofstad le président de notre
groupe au Parlement
européen de tout cas peut-être il y en
aura-t-il un 3è mais on est en
négociation donc je donne la parole à
Alain Lambert en le remerciant de sa
présence l'idée c'est qu'on est en tout
état de cause fini à 8h30 c'est-à-dire
nous
avons tu vas parler combien de temps 20
minutes 20 minutes et puis après une
discussion 30 minutes je te donne et
après 30 minutes ou 40 minutes de
discussion tu as la parole sous nos
appudissement chers amis je voudrais
remercier François et Jean-Pierre
remercier François des
propos fraternels qu'il a eu à mon
endroit tout à l'heure je veux vous dire
que j'ai eu de la fierté de pouvoir
travailler avec les collègues qui sont
ici présents à ses côtés lors de la
présidentielle je pense que le travail
que nous avons mené chacun dans nos
domaines de compétences était un travail
loyal honnête à l'endroit des Français
et que la démocratie pour pouvoir
produire tous ces fruits aura toujours
de plus en plus besoin de loyauté
d'honnêteté de sincérité et quel que
soit les résultats qui ne sont jamais à
la hauteur probablement de nos
espérances il ne faut jamais regretter
d'avoir choisi la loyauté et la
sincérité parce que vient le moment où
de toute façon le fait d'avoir tromper
les citoyens sur la réalité de la
société dans laquelle ils vivent euh se
retournent contre ceux qui les ont
trompé donc euh tout n'est pas dit et
tout n'est pas dit et François sache que
je reste à tes côtés euh autant que tu
le jugeras opportun alors ça me fait
plaisir d'avoir été invité Jean-Pierre
et François sur un sujet qui n'est pas
celui des finances publiques parce que
au bout d'un certain temps quand vous
parlez des finances publiques du déficit
de la dette on se dit ce monsieur doit
être atteint de traumatisme il n'a que
le sujet des déficits et de la dette
dans la bouche et là vous me donnez
l'occasion de revenir à mes premiers
amours c'est-à-dire le droit en effet je
suis né pour le droit un peu dans le
beau métier de notaire et le sujet qui
nous réunit ce soir touche au droit de
la manière dont François l'a présenté
c'est-à-dire au plus concret de la vie
de nos compatriotes vous savez le droit
ça n'est pas un objet de contemplation
comme beaucoup des administration
centrale nous habitue maintenant à le
croire non le droit ce sont des outils
très simples qui visent à nous faire
vivre ensemble de manière harmonieuse
mais de manière concrète aussi et donc
c'est ce dont je vais essayer de vous
parler alors c'est un sujet à
controverse les normes c'est un sujet à
controverse c'est pourquoi pour
l'aborder sereinement je crois prudent
de poser si vous le permettez quelques
axiomes ou quelques affirmations qui me
semblent pas de contradiction sauf si
vous manifestez votre mauvaise humeur le
la première affirmation serait que
l'État et la société ne doivent pas être
confondus si l'État est en quelque sorte
l'incarnation de la société il n'en
reste pas moins qu'il a une relation
avec les citoyens de dominant à dominer
de gouvernant à gouverner ça c'est
souhaitable d'ailleurs mais c'est
toujours ainsi et il doit accepter que
les gouvernés régulièrement le
soumettent à l' vation et dans le
domaine de la norme comme dans le
domaine de la finance comme dans tous
les domaines de l'action publique
première affirmation qui me paraît pas
souffrir de difficultés deuxième
affirmation les administrations
centrales n'ont pas le monopole de
l'intérêt général peut-être peuvent-ell
le croire il y a d'autres
administrations les administrations
sociales les administrations locales des
personnes physiques et morales public
privé qui poursuivent des buts
d'intérêts généraux et qui sont aussi
contributeurs d'un intérêt général donc
il ne faut pas que les administrations
centrales se placent devant les citoyens
comme étant en quelque sorte seul
détentrice de la magie de l'intérêt
général encore une fois affirmation qui
peut se discuter mais je ne le crois pas
la troisème et dernière c'est que les
administration ont la responsabilité de
produire des normes qui doivent
favoriser le fonctionnement optimal de
la société or la vérité oblige à dire
qu'une production massive de texte
n'atteint pas cet objectif euh de
fonctionnement optimal de notre société
alors il est vrai que ce n'est pas
commode de trouver la bonne solution car
il y a deux pontes qui peuvent nous
faire dévaler la première c'est euh le
laisser faire ce que certains d'ailleurs
appellent le libéralisme débridé et on
voit bien que d'ailleurs il ne
fonctionne pas puisque il aboutit
l'insécurité générale et il n'est pas
soutenable et puis il y a le trofèire
c'est-à-dire celui qui le droit qui veut
régler par le menu détail la vie des
sociétés humaines ce qui est proprement
impossible et qui aboutit à un blocage
et c'est peut-être une situation dans
laquelle nous sommes nous le verrons si
vous le voulez bien dans les discussions
que nous aurons à voir à avoir donc ces
affirmations étant prononcées en
espérant qu'elles ne gênne pas votre
conscience euh je voudrais vous dire que
ma conviction est que le droit français
est tombé dans une forme de juridisme et
que il y a urgence à répondre à ce que
francequis disait il y a un instant
c'est-à-dire
saisir le droit en acte c'estàdire tant
qu'il n'est plus qu'un objet de
contradiction de controverse de
d'empêchement il faut impérativement
qu'il reviennne à la réalité et il faut
le ramener à la réalité c'est pourquoi
je vous propose si vous le voulez bien
un parcours de visite de ce sujet du
droit sous le prisme des normes en vous
décrivant d'abord que je pense que cette
crise du droit que not gon est en
train de menacer la démocratie alors
c'est une une inquiétude qui va vous
paraître trop forte je vais m'en
expliquer le deuxème temps de mon propos
sera pourquoi et comment me semble-t-il
on en est arrivé là le troisème temps
c'est faut-il perdre espoir vous verrez
que la réponse est NON et enfin quelques
propositions dont nous pourrions
débattre si vous en êtes d'accord
première partie oui le droit me semble
être une menace pour notre démocratie
l'inflation normative est une charge
réelle qui nous
étouffe montagne nous disait nous avons
en France plus de lois que le reste du
monde tout entier et plus qu'il n'en
faudrait à régler tous les mondes et
bien figurez-vous que ce qu'il a dit est
toujours vrai et
que de nombreux rapports ont dénoncé
cette situation de nombreuses études et
tout est resté lettre morte or
l'asphyxie nous guettete la quantité et
la mauvaise qualité des textes qui sont
produits ont un coûte et ce coûte est
évalué alors l'évaluation peut-être
contestable elle vient de deux
organismes qui ont quand même un peu
pignon sur russe et la Commission
européenne d'un côté et des l'OCDE de
l'autre les deux sont sur une évaluation
de l'ordre de 3 % du PIB c'est-à-dire
que le juridisme l'excès normatif aurait
un coûte d'ordre de grandeur de 3 % du
PIB s'agissant de l'OCDE ils ont fait
une évaluation qui était un peu
différente et là pour la France ils ont
évalué à 60 milliards alors bon il y a
des économistes ici qui savent que les
évaluations comme ça peuvent être
contestables mais enfin quand on arrive
à des chiffres aussi important on voit
bien que la norme a une influence
économique qui est et 60 milliards c'est
3 % du PIB ça tombe pile alors le PIB
change chaque année ce qui veut dire que
voilà ça trop maintenant plus en tout
cas celui qu'on avait prévu nous
François était honnête oui
c'est deuxème aspect donc à mon avis
asphyie deuxème aspect est-ce que le
droit est sève ou poison pour notre
démocratie il est confortable d'aborder
cette question entre juristes parce
qu'alors là c'est un débat d'expert et
on reste sur les grands principe et on
ne finit jamais le débat en revanche
lorsqu'on examine ce ce sujet comme
citoyen on s'aperçoit que le problème le
plus délicat et on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs
que il y a derrière des enjeux qui sont
démocratiques des enjeux qui sont
économiques et que ce n'est pas qu'un
sujet de droit la norme est d'abord un
sujet de société elle elle vise la
manière de concevoir notre organisation
de la société la manière d'écrire le
droit qui régit la siété la manière de
la mettre en œuvre ça révèle la
structure d'organisation de la société
et la conscience qu'ont les gouvernants
de la société qu'ils ont à gouverner et
ça révèle je vous le dis comme je le
pense en tout cas quand je regarde notre
droit un un pessimisme
extraordinairement inquiétant puisque au
fond on fait écrire au juristes tout ce
qui ne va pas et tout ce qui ne va pas
aller et ce qui est sûr de ne pas aller
et si ça va bien quand même on va faire
en sorte que ça aille mal parce que nous
juristes on va régler le problème bien
la question de la norme est également un
sujet politique parce que celui qui
tient la plume tient le pouvoir et le
débat pour tenir la plume est très
important et la bataille pour tenir la
plume est très importante il y a des
législateurs dans cet ou d'ancien
législateur pour d'autres dans cette
maison et normalement c'est le
législateur qui tient la plume
aujourd'hui
la qualité de ce qui produit sans être
désagréable est encore perfectible en
tout cas je vais vous dire comme juriste
elle est problématique alors la plume
est tenue par les administrations
lesquelles produisent alors là du coup
des textes qui sont je vous assure pas
toujours commode je parle à des élus
locaux regardez laartt 2012 1377
page franchement savoir l'expliquer à
ses concitoyens faut faut faut être au
moins agrégé de bat et puis il y a ceux
qui jugent qui sont les magistrats le
rapport de force entre ces faiseurs de
faiseurs de normes législateur
administration magistrature ce rapport
de force démontre que le législateur a
un peu perdu de sa Majesté si j'ose dire
parce que ce qu'il produit sans être
désagréable est plutôt incantatoire que
normatif et benah derrière les
administration écrivent ce qu'elle croi
devoir écrire au bénéfice de la société
c'est un sujet al vous ai je dit c'est
un sujet politique c'est un sujet aussi
économique majeur parce que François a
beaucoup développé le sujet économique
pendant sa campagne mais l'instabilité
des normes puis qu' m'a fait l'honneur
de venir à Alençon dans une entreprise
notamment qui est plutôt bonne et qui
produit souviens-toi des bus ils lui ont
expliqué les difficultés qui étaient les
leurs devant l'instabilité permanente
des règles de de production donc ça pèse
sur l'activité privée ça pèse sur les
finances publiques ça a des coûts
induits qui ne sont jamais sincèrement
chiffrés d'ailleurs et la norme qui
peut-être source de croissance en
revanche quand elle est intelligente
elle est source de ralentissement de la
croissance lorsqu'elle est saute et
hélas il y a beaucoup plus de normes
sautees que de normes intelligentes
actuellement donc si je résume ce que je
viens de vous dire pour cette première
partie le sujet n'est pas seulement
juridique il est sociétal il est
politique il est économique avant d'être
un sujet de droit si nous ne maîtrisons
pas cette intempérance le mot est très
distingué il vient du Conseil d'État
cette intempérance normative B il
implique donc de considérer le sujet euh
comme étant un sujet vraiment important
au plan politique et il faut le traiter
c'est la condition nécessaires au
rétablissement de la compétitivité du
pays au rétablissement de nos finances
publiques mais aussi à mon avis au
rétablissement de la confiance que
peuvent avoir les Français à l'endroit
de leur
organisation la deuxème partie c'est
comment en est-on arrivé là parce que il
est vrai que si
vous voyez ce que nos grands théoriciens
de la matière ont écrit monesquieux
disaient les lois inutiles faaibliss les
lois nécessaires tout est dit si on
savait encore écrire le droit de cette
manière aujourd'hui tout se passe comme
si les auteurs de la norme ignorent tout
des grands principes de notre droit je
peux vous assurer pour les fréquenter en
permanence qu'ils ignorent la hiérarchie
des normes juridiques la dérive consiste
par exemple à vouloir insérer dans la
loi tous les menus détail de la vie des
français ce qui revient à surcharger
dans la loi ce qui revient d'ailleurs à
ignorer la Constitution j'y reviendrai
mais ce qui revient à surcharger dans la
loi de manière absolument excessive
toutes les dispositions qui normalement
relèvent du règlement choisir
systématiquement le niveau de la loi il
paraît que c'est pour donner de la
solennité mais choisir systématiquement
le niveau de la loi loi pour inclure
insérer de la norme je vous laisse
imaginer la rigidité que cela entraîne
parce que pour modifier une loi c'est
pas à vous que j'expliquerai il faut un
an aujourd'hui alors que si euh vous
avez un simple arrêté voir une annexe à
un arrêté vous pouvez la modifier en 15
jours vous voyez donc que si nous
voulons que notre drit droit revienne
compétitif un jour il va peut-être
falloir changer un petit peu de méthode
je je voudrais oser une caricature pour
vous montrer comment on peut quand on
est sous ou quand on gouverne ceement
euh paralyser un pays imaginez puisquon
est en train de charger dans la loi tout
ce qui relève aujourd'hui du règlement
quand ce n'a d'ailleurs pas de la
circulaire pourquoi pas tout mettre dans
la Constitution comme ça au moins ça
serait fini nous pourrions avoir un
droit qui serait dou solide et et
définitif donc il faut en finir pour
bien faire la norme qui est un enjeu
démocratique autant que technique je
crois qu'il faut euh utiliser les outils
de droit et respecter les règles qui
sont fixées par notre droit la
Constitution figurez-vous a tout prévu
34 et 37 de la Constitution disent
clairement ce qui relève de la loi
clairement ce qui relève du règlement
violer tous les jours par ceux qui
produisent de la norme respecter le
droit de la norme que je vous disais il
y a un instant c'est permettre
d'adaptation permanente de droit si dans
une réglementation technique par exemple
espérons tout de même que la technologie
et la science progresse tous les jours
si vous choisissez de mettre une
prescription technique dans une annexe
ça veut dire que votre texte initial
demeure puisque ce texte ne propose que
des objectifs d'intérêt général que tout
le monde partage et les modalités
technique pour atteindre cet objectif
d'intérêt général peuvent évoluer on
modifie l'annexe pour la mettre à jour
en fonction des progrès de la science et
des techniques tout le monde sait faire
ça chez les juristes mais pensez-vous on
dirait qu'ils sont payés à la production
de signes qu'il les imposent à travers
leur production
normative donc nous ne respectons ni la
Constitution ni son esprit et nous nous
pénalisons notre pays derrière tout ça
je ne voudrais pas éviter un sujet qui
nous concerne
tous ne sommes-nous pas victimes d'une
addiction à la
sécurité l'ambition de couvrir par le
droit l'infiniie diversité des activités
humaines je cite encore Montaigne
témoigne d'un ôme français qui est
probablement la peur non avouée de
l'avenir une peur si forte qu'elle
conduit à prétendre prémunir contre
toute doléance contre toute véléité de
demander des comptes contre tout risque
protéger jusqu'à l'infini notre pauvre
société qui n'en demande pas tant
prévenir tenter de tout prévoir régir
par avance dans les moindres détails
tels sont les conséquences
impressionnante du principe de
précaution qui a été intégré dans le
préambule de notre Constitution au point
d'ailleurs que au nom du principe de
constitution du du principe de
précaution on de on rend applica des
normes antisismiques sur des territoires
qui n'ont jamais connu de problèmes de
cette nature le la terni a jamais
tremblé aucun expert n'a pensé qu'elle
puisse trembler un jour mais que
voulez-vous au nom du principe de
précaution on applique ce genre de chose
ce qui a pour effet de renchérir de 20 %
le coût de la construction face au
principe de précaution il est urgent et
ça Jean-Claude Bou tenait beaucoup et je
l'ai complètement accompagne dans cette
idée d'affirmer que on a le droit de
vouloir réhabiliter le droit au risque
en
France ça nous paraît une condition du
progrès scientifique et technique des
innovations qui impliquent probablement
parfois quand même des transgressions et
des explorations hors normes euh et la
créativité est par essence un peu hors
norme donc il elle n'est pas
incompatible à nos yeux avec la sagesse
et le discernement c'est pourquoi il
faut réhabiliter le droit au risque en
France j'en viens à la troisème partie
rassurez-vous donc je je il y en a que
quatre donc euh et si la la partie
espoir pour ne pas vous décourager et si
la crise du droit qui est une vraie
crise à mes yeux était l'occasion de
réinventer le droit alors vous allez
vous dire à son âge vraiment il est pas
raisonnable d'avoir des idées pareilles
parce que ça ne marchea jamais et bien
on ne sait jamais moi je pense que de
toute façon on est dans un état de
Paradise tel qu'il est possible
probablement de se dire qu'on peut
réinventer le droit le constat est
unanime trop de loi tu es la loi trop de
règles tu la règles donc pour revenir à
une conception du droit qui
constituerait un ensemble cohérent
intelligible servi par une langue claire
dense précise mais il faut revenir au
textes fondamentaux que les Français ont
eux même produit c'était pas il y a pas
si longtemps et d'ailleurs ça a servi de
modèle dans le monde figurez-vous et
voilà depuis on s'est mis à bavarder
mais c'est pas
complètement imaginable que ce soit
fatal et que nous bavardions jusqu'à la
nuit des temps non je pense qu'on
peut susciter une révolution salutaire
la matière et revenir et c'est pour ça
que nous avions appelé ça un choc de
compétitivité juridique alors le
président de la république ayant utilisé
le mot quelques jours après nous avons
été soupçonnés de plagiat nous avons
revendiqué néanmoins de l'avoir utilisé
avant donc ces enjeux de lutte contre
cette intempérance sont cruciaux vous
savez pour la nation et nous savons
qu'il y aura des résistances je veux les
traiter en quelques mots pour vous
montrer que ça ne va' pas ça ne nous a
pas empêché de l'aborder avec espoir
cependant
oui l'abrogation des normes fait des
mécontents partout les gens sont très
mécontent parce qu'il y a des normes
mais alors je vais vous dire les groupes
de pression qui sont à l'origine des
normes ils veillent mais comme à la
prunelle de leurs yeux donc pour le
corps politique c'est incroyablement
dangereux de dire on va alléger les
normes mais les parlementaires j'ai
connu le métier j'étais aussi é
naturellement de déposer des amendements
euh les parlementaires rêvent les
ministres rêvent d'avoir une noi qui
porte leur nom donc qu'il va bien
falloir aussi discipliner tout ça je
crois que l'exécutif doit aussi
s'habituer à l'idée et personne ne lui
reprochait vraiment de ne pas vouloir
tout prévoir qu'il laisse aussi de temps
en temps la société s'organiser quelle
victoire monsieur le Président quelle
victoire si nous parvenions dans notre
pays à vaincre les résistances
corporatistes je pense que c'est un
enjeu qui est extrêmement important et
croyez-moi la France a tout à gagné à
remettre les notair par exemple non
pardon
non j'avais compris que le temps des
questions était
après mais la question peut-être posée
parce que naturellement la réponse a été
préparé alors la France a tout à gagné à
remettre de l'ordre dans son propre
droit elle redresserait l'image dégradée
qui est la sienne dans le monde pour sa
compétitivité euh elle redressait son
image auprès des entreprises des
entreprises françaises mais aussi des
entreprises qui sont candidates à
l'implantation en France parce que quoi
qu'on dise la France reste un pays quand
même qui peut être attractif et ça
redonnerait de la crédibilité également
aux parlementaires européens pour que le
droit européen le droit communautaire
lui-même ne tombe pas dans les défauts
que je suis en train de développer je
n'en ai pas parlé à ce stade parce que
je pense que vos questions couvriront
cette ce sujet et enfin de remettre un
peu d'ordre dans notre démocratie en
prouvant aux citoyens que ses
représentants font le droit pour l' pour
l'intérêt général et ils ne le font pas
pour la somme des intérêts particuliers
qui est représenté par tous les groupes
de pression qui défilent dans les rues
toute la journée donc ce changement de
paradigme pour l'élaboration euh de
normes à venir et et de révolutionner
notre culture administrative et
politique serait une source infinie de
réenchantement je crois des Français à
l'endroit du fonctionnement de leur pays
et je pense que dans la crise que le
monde occidental traverse nous n'avons
que peu de moyens immédiats à pour
inverser les tendances lourdes euh il ne
tient qu'à notre volonté de changer
notre paradigme juridique en revanche
certes le droit européen ou
communautaire est une contrainte qu'il
faut intégrer et je pourrais expliquer à
travers vos questions qu' faut pas
l'intégrer comme nous le faisons parce
que nous surtransposons ce qui veut dire
que nous donnons une mauvaise réputation
au droit communotaire mais il ne tient
qu'à nous de changer notre obje notre
corpus juridique il y a des tas de
d'outils pour le faire et je suis à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions sur ce sujet
entre le droit dur c'estàdire le droit
obligatoire qu'il s'impose à tout le
monde et le droit qu'on appelle le droit
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire le droit
volontaire il y a place à un droit que
nous qualifions en intelligent
c'est-à-dire que les objectifs sont
fixés dans le droit dur dans le droit
obligatoire et les modalités les
prescriptions techniques sont fixé dans
le droit souple c'est-à-dire dans le
droit qu'on appelle volontaire c'est
tout le registre de ce qu'on appelle la
normalisation de type apnor ISO et
cetera et cetera et vous vous apercevez
moi je le vois puceque je préside la
commission qui s'applique aux
collectivités local lorsque vous
regardez la manière dont ces normes qui
sont des toutes des normes volontaires
ont été écrites elles sont écrites dans
un vocabulaire et dans un système
normatif qui est un système de qualité
et non pas un système
de de
coer comment comment vous dire pour dire
les choses simplement euh une règle de
qualité euh peut avoir une échelle de 1
à 10 euh une règle de droit soit vous la
transgressez soit vous la respez c'est
pas du tout la même méthode donc on voit
bien que pour faire progresser notre
droit il faut absolument introduire
d'autres mécanismes de droit que je
qualifie
d'intelligent voilà donc pour le droit
intelligent et j'en arrive à la dernière
partie qui
est j'avais dit que je ne parlais pas de
droit communautaire mais pour ceux qui
connaissent l'histoire de l'Europe et
dans cette maison il y en a très
nombreux il y a dans le droit
communautaire ce qu'on a appelé la
nouvelle
approche la nouvelle approche a consisté
à renoncer à l'idée qui consistait à
essayer d'harmoniser les droits
nationaux dans les compétences
communautaires parce que c'était une
œuvre qui était inatteignable et alors
justement on a choisi une nouvelle
approche qui a consisté à s'inspirer des
droits nationaux comme étant des
éléments de référence donc des guides
pratiques des des guides de bonnes Prati
et cetera et on a adopté une nouvelle
approche c'est tout à fait possible en
droit français pour l'instant lorsque
vous êtes une administration dans Sa
Majesté vous dites vous préscrivez vous
prenez un arrêté puis pour vous dites
après tout si je m décret ça fait encore
mieux non vous prenez un décret et voilà
vous avez décidé du devenir du monde je
termine quelques propositions des
propositions très rapides très simples
surtout pour ouvrir le débat si notre
Président nous y autorise alors réformer
notre droit c'est en fait le moderniser
c'est tout simplement le mettre à jour
il y a néanmoins des gros sujets à
traiter je prends un sujet qui est celui
de la
proportionnalité le droit la la
proportionnalité le principe de
proportionnalité existe en droit du
travail en droit pénal en droit
communautaire bien sûr sauf en droit
administratif les administrations
françaises ont décidé que la proportion
ité ne pourrait pas s'appliquer parce
qu'ell veut le pouvoir de Paris décider
de la manière dont les choses vont se
faire dans le Berne et dans l'Orne et
cetera très bien mais peut y avoir
éventuellement des situations un petit
peu différentes d'ailleurs je crois me
souvenir que dans le Code civil il y a
eu quelques problèmes au départ parce
que le droit d'è dans le béarme était
quand même réputé ne pas devoir être
changé immédiatement si mes souvenirs
sont bons mais ça fait partie
de de de l'histoire de deuxème sujet le
principe de sécurité juridique le
principe de sécurité juridique existe
dans loi communautaire il existe dans
quasiment toutes les constitutions du
monde le Conseil constitutionnel dit
c'est un principe tacite et personne ne
veut l'écrire c'est quand même
extraordinaire et pourquoi n voulons
nous pas l'écrire c'est parce que ça
gêne dans
administration je crois vraiment que je
ne fais pas de l'anti administrative
primaire je pense que il faut savoir
dans un pays par qui on veut être
gouverné soit on veut être en démocratie
être gouverné par des gens qu'on peut
changer soit on admet une autre on
souscrit à uneautres façon d'organis
d'organiser la société et c'est de s'en
remettre à ceux qui par leur qualité de
capacité à à l'emporter dans un concours
à l'âge de 25 ans peuvent jusqu'à la fin
de leur carrière décider de devenir de
leur
concitoyens trè aspect il faut avoir le
courage de
dépénaliser le domaine des normes le
code pénal français n'est pas du tout
défectueux il a toutes les dispositions
pourquoi avoir dans chaque texte qui
touche les marchés publics c'est le
pompon mais il y a une histoire qui peut
l'expliquer euh
l'environnement vous avez du pénal
partout ce qui fait que tout
gestionnaire qu'il soit élu ou
administratif dit oh là là là le risque
administratif je veux bien le prendre
mais les risque pénal je ne le prends
pas je prends une mauvaise décision je
le sais mais je la prends parce que je
ne peux pas prendre de risque pénal donc
il faut oser dire que on veut
dépénaliser le domaine des normes
j'eneviens EN mentalité et parlant des
mentalités je voudrais en quelque sorte
interpeller mes deux voisins dont chacun
sait qu'ils sont des des enseignants et
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir si la
cooherition est la seule méthode pour
faire évoluer de Man ière vertueuse les
comportements et je me pose la question
par exemple s'agissant de l'enseignement
si par exemple pour arriver à ce que
l'élève progresse la sanction l'autorité
autoritariste la menace et cetera sont
les seuls instruments de motivation
ou si de temps en temps on ne peut pas
arriver en utiliser d'autres pour
conduire celui qu'on veut faire
progresser sur un chemin son de vertu en
tout cas de progrès il en est de même
croyez-moi pour les actions d'intérêt
général ça n'est pas en prescrivant des
normes à sorties des sanctions les plus
insensées que les comportements des
citoyens vont changer je vous le dis
parce que je connais la pratique des
Français j'ai écrit leur dernière
volonté déjà depuis 35 ans pour beaucoup
d'entre eux ils n'ont aucune idée
lorsque la norme vient les narguer et
quasiment quelque part les les les les
les les les les les interroger c'est de
la contourner c'est pourquoi je pense
que nous devons avoir des normes
impératives et nous devons avoir
d'autres qui sont desénmes de références
et de qualité j'en viens à la conclusion
avec un titre qui m'a amusé je ne sais
pas s'il fallait mettre un s en vacances
ou pas et si on mettait notre droit en
vacances alors mettre notre droit en
vacances en mon esprit c'est quoi c'est
d'abord il faut absolument que le droit
crée de la sécurité de l'harmonie de
l'intelligibilité de l'efficacité mais
est-ce qu'on ne peut quand même pas
affirmer que les administrations central
comme je l'ai dit au début n'ont pas le
monopole de l'intérêt général que c'est
aussi ce cet intérêt général le fruit
quotidien du travail des
Français que le renouveau que le sursaut
que le réenchantement des français passe
aussi par l'adaptation de notre pays et
que le droit administratif français qui
est pratiqué professionnel
écoutez bien le chiffre qui est le droit
administratif français est pratiqué
professionnellement par un actif
Français sur 4 il est subi par tous les
autres ce droit doit être
assoupli la règle bureaucratique doit
répondre aux attentes des Français il
faut lever les dysfonctionnements au
lieu de créer des dysfonctionnements ce
que beaucoup de règles aujourd'hui cré
il faut changer le climat de routine de
rigidité de contrainte d'irrespons ilité
qui se diffuse à tous les étages la
brisure du
carcan qui est un leg paralysant du du
passé constituerait je vous le dis comme
je le crois un signal très fort de
changement attendu par les Français les
fonctionnaires qui sont actuellement
tiraillés entre de multiples
contradictions pourrai enfin appliquer
la norme avec discernement et le droit
administratif aurait pour fonction de
favoriser l'exercice par les citoyens de
leur responsabilité et non de l'étenir
dans un état d'assister d'incapable
juridique l'organisation administrative
qui en découlerait partirait des besoins
des usagers et non du droit des
administrations lequel retrouverait sa
véritable fonction c'est-à-dire
organiser la vie administrative de la
France placer l'administration en
cohérence et en unité au service des
administré vous savez la monopolisation
du droit par l'État doit trouver ses
limit
la folie normative qui s'est emparé du
pays justifie de reconnaître aujourd'hui
que le droit administratif notre droit
administratif est devenu dangereux que
son abondance son instabilité son
insécurité
entraîne un déséquilibre au profit de
l'État mais au en défaveur des citoyens
qu' soit entreprise ou ménage et la
prééminence de l'intérêt général que ce
droit administratif éit réputé garantir
c'est métamorphoser en intérêt des
administrations ou présumé intérêt des
administrations parce que on sait pas
qui c'est au final donc c'est un nouveau
droit qu'il nous faut faire naître afin
de ne pas nous faire emporter par le
modèle juridique anglo-saxon dont
certains pourrai rêver finalement au
final puisque on narrive pas à trouver
de solution avec notre propre système
donc le vrai droit doit être retrouvé
celui qui reconnaît la pronté de la lo
loi celui qui respecte la jurisprudence
celui qui s'inspire de la doctrine celui
qui écoute la coutume le pouvoir
règlementaire doit réapprendre son rôle
il doit l'exercer conformément à la
Constitution au final les
administrations doivent retrouver le
fondement de leur existence c'est-à-dire
celui de servir et non celui de dominer
celui d'ordonner et non pas de
régimenter celui de traduire en droit
les faits dont François parlait tout à
l'heure et non pas de les nier ou de les
paralyser au fond de transformer la peur
des Français en
espoir
merci alors tout le
monde mesure dans sa propre vie ce que
sont les blocages innombrables les pu
auquel on est soumis quand on est je pas
artisan
commerçant petit chef
d'entreprise et chacun le voit dans son
secteur d'activité moi je veux vous
parler
simplement d'un secteur que je connais
une seconde que je connais bien et vous
en parler une seconde
c'est la loi qui est en train d'être et
qui s'appelle pompeusement et tout à
fait à tort on le verra loi de
refondation de
l'école j'ai
essayé de la lire j'y suis arrivé par un
effort de volonté énorme alors c'est une
loi qui est faite d'une série de
corrections à une loi précédente qui
était la loi Jospin je rappelle que j'ai
refusé moi de faire une loi de de ce de
cet ordre parce que une loi qui n'est
qu'une loi que j'appelle votive vous
savez il y a des fêtes votive c'est des
faites pour faire des
vœux c'est une loi vetive il y a que des
vœux pieux
elle fait cette loi 47
pages de correction à la loi précédente
et 48 pages
d'annexe il n'y a dans cette de
substantiel que la suppression des
choses solides qu' avait dans la loi
précédente par exemple on avait créer le
droit pour un enfant qui se sentait mal
à l'école à 14 ans de pouvoir commencer
à apprendre un métier on le supprime on
avait organisé la scolarité les
enseignants qui sont là savent ce que je
veux dire en
cycle au sein de l'école primaire TR
cycl on le supprime
on
avait indiqué comme ça un certain nombre
de de choses solides et utile on les
supprime c'est une loi je vous le dis
qui ne sera lu par personne le Parlement
y travaille depuis une lecture à
l'Assemblée une lecture au Sénat et puis
maintenant vient la deuxième lecture à
l'Assemblée il y aura la deuxième
lecture au Sénat personne cette loi làà
vous l'avez ententre les mains c'est ça
ou je partage votre sentiment
merci personne ne la
lira quand vous pensez qu'on est besoin
qu'on a besoin de faire une loi une loi
pour l'organisation de la
semaine
c'est c'est une chose assez drôle il y
avait une controverse entre des communes
de ma région euh euh d'un côté les
enseignants protestent parce que on va
remettre une demi-journée ça discute
dans tous les sens je vais pas reprendre
le
sujet et alors il y a eu une controverse
entre deux maèires et alors on s'est
aperçu tu parlais des faits on s'est
aperçu que il y a 4 ans qu'on a changé
l'organisation de la semaine en
réalité dans la commune où je suis
modestement élu la commune de poau on
avait organisé la semaine de 4 jours
depuis 25
ans la loi précédente on s'en FO avait
fait la semaine de 4 jours et dans la
commune voisine de
Bayonne je crois que c'est à Bayonne
mais c'estit vérifié on a découvert que
malgré le vote de la semaine de 4 jours
on avait maintenu la semaine de 4 jours
et demi personne s'en est aperçu les
faits étit infiniment plus fort que la
loi que la norme et c'est d'une
absurdité colossal on a passé 4 jours à
l'Assemblée nationale à discuter de
savoir si on avait le droit d'organiser
des cours en anglais je vous prie de
m'excuser mais je suis obligé de
rappeler que des cours en langue
étrangère il y en a dans tous les lycées
internationaux français dans toutes les
dans toutes les sections européennes de
tous les lycées classiques et que même
des cours en langue régional il y en a
dans toutes les écoles par immersion et
que donc c'est une pure et c'est un pure
et simple dés équilibre des esprits
qu'on en vienne à discuter de loi
pendant des jours et des jours à faire
une polémique devant l'opinion pour
quelque chose qui existe partout et qui
devrait être du ressort même pas du
règlement même pas de l'arrêter mais de
la compétence de la responsabilité du
chef d'établissement surtout quand il
s'agit d'un président d'université
puisqueun proviseur de lycée et un
principal de collège et même un
directeur d'école Pr m organise tous les
jours dans leur établissement des cours
dans la langue qui étrangère qu'il
souhaitent nous sommes un pays qui est
tombé sur la tête j'ai fini ça c'est un
simple exemple dans l'éducation mais
alors ça se vérifie quand on veut j'ai
montré à la télévision l'autre
jour parce que ça ça coûte des dizaines
de milliers d'emplois à mon avis j'ai
montré le droit du travail
suisse
loi sur le travail
suisse moins de 4 % de chômage en
Suisse 300000 français qui traversent la
frontière tous les jours pour aller
travailler en Suisse au passage des
salaires plus élevés que nous en avons
en France voilà la loi sur le travail
suisse voilà le code du travail
français 2
kg 3000 pages j'exagère 3000 pages
j'exagère de beaucoup
2795 bon je triche un tout petit peu je
veux je dois l'honnêteté de dire qu'ici
il y a la jurisprudence et là pas mais
enfin vous voyez une chose très simple
c'est que si vous
êtes l'épouse de l'artisan qui a
5 salariés ça vous pouvez le
comprendre
le lire
l'étudier même si c'est un peu ardu ça
vous pouvez
pas et ceci
organise ceci organise la
protection la protection de au moins
trois
entités c'est la protection du monopole
des
avocats c'est la protection de la
prééminence des grandes entreprises
parce que eux ont des d
RH multiples et variés des spécialistes
pour aller chercher là-dedans l'habileté
qui leur permettra de passer au travers
deses gouttes et un tout petit peu je
dis ça à voix basse des
syndicats parce que c'est c'est une
c'est un argument de
vente
de de la syndicalisation puisque eux il
peuvent connaître avec des permanents
tout ça et bien ceci à mon avis coûte
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois à la
France c'était pour illustrer que cette
espèce de
prolifération dans laquelle nous vivons
de règlement de contrôle de lois de de
de texte administratif de toute nature
est en fait une paralysie de la vie du
pays et que donc l'exigence de
simplification qui répond qui devrait
entraîner l'exigence de lisibilité et de
et de
d'efficacité selon moi c'est une ardente
obligation comme disait général de
Gaulle pour le plan c'est une ardente
obligation je ne sais pas qui aura le
courage de le faire parce que dès
l'instant que vous vous apprêtez à
toucher à tout ça alors vous avez beau
avoir le sourire enjoleur de Alain
Lambert à ce moment-là se déclenche de
partout des protestations et des groupes
depression c'était deux illustrations
concrètes de la folie contre laquelle il
essaie de prémunir notre
pays vous avez la parole une seule règle
alternance masculin
féminin on n pas fini non plus de
discuter deoi je vais faire genre dans
la loi sur l'école je vais faire une
toute petite intervention qui concerne
non pas nécessairement les lois et et
les lois qui sont faites ce qu'il y a
c'est que vous avez tous remarqué que le
gouvernement a pris un certain nombre de
lois qui consiste à dire je vais taxer
tout ce qui bouge du coup il y a plus
rien qui bouge et il y a une paralysie
du pays qui est quand même assez patente
et moi je suis ingénieur j'ai une petite
société et dans les réflexions que j'ai
faites j'ai pensé à un dispositif qui
permettrait de ne plus taxer tout ce qui
bouge mais d'encourager tout ce qui
bouge et d'encourager tout ce qui bouge
et qui crée de l'emploi et et la seule
chose que je vous demande bon je vais
pas vous exposer le dispositif puisque
de toute façon c'est un dispositif qui
est très simple mais même s'il est en
huit points et qui tient en une page je
vous demanderai simplement monsieur beou
d'avoir la gentillesse de le lire et je
suis sûr que vous comprendrez très bien
et d'essayer de voir ce que vous pouvez
en tant que président de parti en tirer
voilà je suis ingénieur je suis pas un
juriste si vous avez trouvé ça je vous
promets une petite mais bien réelle
statue
donc je vous promets de vous lire Alain
Lambert le lira aussi mon adresse c'est
baou@baou.fr je je vais vous laisser je
vais vous laisser le document je
laisserai à Monsieur Lambert aussi parce
que j'ai constaté que c'était une
personne qui avait une certaine
ouverture d'esprit qui est à même de
pouvoir voir ce que d'autres gens qui
sont pas juristes peuvent essayer de
créer merci
beaucoup
féminin
merci euh parlant du droit communautaire
et puisque vous dites juste raison que
le droit français et le droit romain est
assez rigide est-ce que on n'est pas
menacé par le Common Law qui lui est
beaucoup plus souple et qui s'introduit
de façon assez insidieuse dans la
réglementation
communautaire parce que
les les
lois étant enfin les directives étant
faites au consensus c'est peut-être plus
simple et plus souple de ça de de
s'approcher du Common
Law sur cet aspect vous avez raison de
dire que le doit le droit de common law
est un droit de
jurisprudence pour les continentaux on
considère que c'est un droit moins
prévisible puisque il repose sur la
décision du juge lorsqu'un conflit naît
mais cette affirmation ne tient que si
le droit que nous écrivons est
prévisible et dès lors que ce droit que
nous écrivons ne serait plus prévisible
ne serait plus sécure ne serait nurait
plus l'intelligibilité dont nous parlons
tout à l'heure il n'aurait plus
l'effectivité que nous lui reconnaissons
par rapport au droit de common law et
vous avez raison c'était d'ailleurs dans
une partie de mon propos je pense que le
temps est venu où la bascule vers le
droit de comm la est possible si le
droit continental et le droit français
puisque nous sommes en France vient à
être aussi
euh insécure que ce qu'il est aussi
brouillon que ce qu'il est vous avez
raison cette menace est grande alors au
niveau de l'Union européenne il y a des
parlementaires européens dans cette
salle je suis je serai donc très
au-dessus de ma condition de répondre je
je pense que la partie n'est pas n'est
pas perdue parce que pour que l'Union
européenne fonctionne il faut que les
systèmes juridiques puissent fonctionner
dans leur tradition mais il demeure que
l'influence du système anglo-saxon est
de plus en plus grande à raison aussi de
la capacité qu'on les anglo-saxons à
communiquer
masculin euh bonjour Michel Marcal adj
mer de versaill et président d' office
HLM donc je ne vous donnerai pas la
liste des normes absurdes sur dans
lesquelles je me cogne tous les jours il
y a de quoi faire rire beaucoup juste un
exemple he trois pris téléphones fixes
dans des chambres étudiantes de 17 m²
enfin vous imaginez voilà euh je
voudrais juste rajouter vous un point un
point d'inquiétude c'estàd que vous
disiez que souvent quand on parlait de
simplifier les normes il y avait
beaucoup de résistan je pense qu'une
partie des résistances sont ceux qui ont
peur qu'on supprime les normes mais
aussi de ceux qui ont peur qu'en
simplifiant on en rajoute d'autres et je
reprendrai l'exemple de François Berrou
sur le code du travail la CFTC a un très
bon abécédaire juridique et quand le
gouvernement précédent a simplifié le
code du travail laabcdr juridique a été
multiplié par deux en épaisseur pour
faire le même travail
c'était une contribution féminin
oui bonjour d'abord merci pour votre
exposé je voulais juste rebondir sur la
question qui a été faite par par rapport
au Common Law et je voulais simplement
vous demander ce que vous penseiez du
fait que si on tendait vers quelque
chose qui ressemblait plus à du Common
Law alors ça transférait une sorte de
pouvoir que vous avez très bien décrit
qui est aujourd'hui plutôt dans la main
du législateur et qui serait qui
tendrait à passer du côté finalement du
juriste et de l'avocat puisque tout ce
qui ne serait pas écrit au préalable
finalement ce serait débattu après
c'est-à-dire que est-ce qu'il y a pas le
danger finalement que tout ce qui ne va
pas être prévu à l'avance va être encore
plus sujet à être conflictuel par par
ailleurs
et un mot sur la la question masculine
je pense qu'il est possible de
simplifier sans ajouter c'est une
question de technique que les juristes
connaissent bien mais il faut de la
volonté politique c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut que celui qui tient la plume la
maîtrise s'il la confie déjà un tiers
sans regarder ce que ce tiers écrit
c'est foutu donc je pense qu'on peut
simplifier sans
augmenté en revanche il faut ne pas
avoir peur parce que si vous vous
contentez de la norme actuelle on est
quand même perdu ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure est significatif trois prises
de courant dans une dans un appartement
qui éit VI prise de téléphoneééone
téléphone attendez sur les prises j'ai
une autre histoire très rapide à vous
raconter les deux constructeurs
principaux de d'automobile en France
n'ont pas été capables de se mettre
d'accord sur les prises pour recharger
des batteries de voiture euh électriqu
mant quoi c'est la norm allemande qui va
s'imposer et là du coup là on aurait pu
faire de la norme intelligente on aurait
pu s'en occuper le redressement
productif aurait pu faire quelque chose
d'intelligent au lieu de faire du
nationalisme de débrider donc on voit
bien que quand on a une norme
intelligente à produire et ben
finalement on est tellement occupé par
les normes stupide qu'on n pas le temps
de s'en
occuper chers jeunes voir féminine
la question que vous posez est est est
passionnante pour un juriste elle est
compliquée en revanche à traiter pour
que tout le monde suive notre
raisonnement les s'il y a deux systèmes
juridiques c'est parce que il y a deux
conceptions de la vie différentes euh le
système juridique anglo-saxon est un
système juridique basé un peu sur le
rapport de force et je ne porte pas de
jugement de valeur je ne porte pas de
jugement de parce que quand on a autant
massacré ce qui faisait la singularité
et à mon avis la force du droit
continental on est mal placé pour
critiquer le droit voisin qui était au
départ peut-être moins conforme à notre
propre conception de la vie mais qui va
finir par être plus effectif que celui
que nous avons nous massacré donc je
reviens à la comparaison que j'essaie de
faire le droit anglo-saxon est plus
fondé sur une sorte de rapport de force
plutôt que sur une règle qui était
dictée par le législateur alors ça
comporte des avantages c'est que partout
où les gens s'entendent bien ça va plus
vite et ça va c'est infiniment plus
efficace en revanche malheur à ceux pour
lesquels ça se passe mal parce que ils
se retrouvent devant des juridictions
avec des batteries d'avocat de part et
d'autre et je ne suis pas sûr que leurs
intérêts soient bien pris en compte en
revanche notre système continental avait
ce mérite d'avoir comme je l'ai dit euh
une sorte de de recueil au départ
c'était un recueil de règles de vie en
société qui avaient été écrit dans une
langue très claire très dense très
d'ailleurs très très constante on peut
prendre des
exemples vous êtes pour beaucoup d'entre
vous ma l'article du Code civil qui dit
chaque époux contribuera aux charges du
mariage à proportion de ses facultés
respectives et bien si les juristes
aujourd'hui écrivaient C même article on
dirait chaque époux contribue aux
charges de mariage en fonction de la
moyenne des revenus des 5 dernières
années pondéré
par c'est très probable or le premier
texte a très très bien marché et en
effet ça a traversé la société il a été
écrit en 1804 figurez-vous et que la
société très différente de celle de 2013
et bien lorsqu'il y a un conflit entre
des épouses sur la contribution au
charge du mariage et bien on trouve des
solutions parce que la règle qui a été
posée a été écr é en termes généraux je
je résume ma réponse je pense que le
temps est venu de mettre notre droit au
niveau qui était le sien et à l'ambition
qu'il portait c'est-à-dire d'être de de
nature à favoriser une vie harmonieuse
sur son territoire s'il l'oublie et bien
il passera le droit anglo-saxon finira
par
s'imposer simplement une observation au
passage
je
crains que cette différence de capacité
entre les légistes de 1804 et les ceux
qui
écrivent griffon la loi aujourd'hui
viennent aussi de ce que la maîtrise de
la langue
séffondée je pense que c'est
profondément relié
euh à des problèmes d'éducation
que c'est profondément relié au fait que
les légistes de 1804 étaient des gens
qui avaient travaillé le latin qu'ils
écrivaient couramment que donc ils
savaiit ce qu'était l'histoire des mots
le sens profond que cette histoire
transmet je pense que ils ne savent plus
écrire y compris quelquefois dans les
plus hautes magistratures
c'est c'est un c'est un problème
désespérant mais ça joue un très grand
rôle et et le l'intelligibilité de la
loi elle dépend aussi de la capacité de
ceux qui sont chargés de
l'écrire donc on a là une on a là une
question très importante et et au
Parlement dans ces deux chambres c'est
vrai aussi mais je ferme cette
parenthèse
bonsoir François ptier de tri en
fait poser cette question
là vous vous évoquez la loi là
effectivement sur l'éducation nationale
il y a 577 députés il en a aucun qui
écit au scandale dans le processus
d'élaboration de cette loi il y a pas
une intervention préalable pour
arrêter le
désastre tu parles de ton expérience je
parle de la
mienne bon la réponse est non il y a
personne
pour alors ça tient à beaucoup de choses
ça tient au fait que il n'y a plus
d'indépendance du législatif par rapport
à l'exécutif et que donc toute la
majorité est là pour dire amen et que
c'est formidable et qu'un texte comme ça
a jamais été écrit c'est le texte le
plus
nunus qu'on puisse expliquer qu'on vous
dit qu'on fera des parcours de formation
artistique dans tous les degré de
l'éducation tu
parles qu'est-ce que la loi va changer
rien c'est
verbeux c'est c'est mal écrit c'est
vague c'est non il y a personne personne
pour dire ça va pas dans la majorité et
dans l'opposition on est toujours contre
tout souvent alors par rapport à ce
texte à juste titre je le dis d'autant
plus que j'avais l'espoir que payon
serait un bon ministre de l'Éducation
parce que je croyais qu'il connaissait
les choses et puis qu'il avait hélas il
n'a pas résisté à essayer de se faire
bien voir de de groupes de pression à
l'intérieur de l'éducation c'est un
texte pour pour moi
qui a essayé de ne pas ajouter de texte
de de faire attention à pas faire des
réformes qui n'en était pas c'est un
texte désespérant mais il y a personne
pour le dire dans la vie parlementaire
parce que il n'y a plus de parole à la
tribune qui puisse s'imposer et se faire
entendre on discute de ce qu'on vous
propose on ajoute des amendements les
uns de suppression les autres
d'addition ça a été examiné par les
commission
combien de parlementaires à la vérité
ont regardé le texte à la
vérité à l'Assemblée en tout cas assez
peu
bon voilà en tout cas mon expérience
tout ceci c'est l'affaiblissement du
Parlement et de la liberté de parole du
parlementaire qui peut dire à l'exécutif
vous êtes en train de
nous mener par le bout du nez on va pas
se laisser mener par le bout du nez non
c'est c'est c'est un peu désespérant
mais toi ton expérience
Jean-Pierre juste un mot il y avait dans
dans la loi en discussion et qui va être
adopté dans dans l'indifférence générale
d'opinion même chose pour le la loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
par parenthèse bien c'est quand même
stupéfiant enfin alors que la priorité
était la jeunesse et cetera bon très
bien non il y avait une nouveauté
historique qui était de dire ou de
tenter de dire au au point de départ que
ce serait une loi d'orientation comme
bien d'autres et de
programmation la programmation est passé
à la trappe au fil de la de la
discussion or ça c'était assez neuf dès
lors que ça si non mais ça remettait ça
remettit dans le débat public et d'abord
sous ses formes parlementaires euh la
question de la de la programmation ça
veut dire la question des contenus tout
simplement qu'est-ce qu'on enseigne aux
enfants et au aux jeunes dans ce pays
vous savez que la programmation est
remise au calendre grec de d'une
commission d'un conseil national des
programmes rénovés comme toujours et
cetera bon il y a là un
dysfonctionnement alors du coup dès lors
que ça laisse toute toute l'attitude
désormais puisquil ne s'agit plus que de
l'orientation je dirais systémique en
l'état du du
mamouth ça laisse
toute toute élasticité tout tout
vagabondage possible et au point de et
au point de rencontre
euh l'impossibilité à distinguer la
programmation de
l'orientation et du coup impossibilité
absolue du système
à l'évaluation la norme est envahissante
hein elle n'est pas appliquée à des
contenus et du coup l'évaluation de ce
qui se passe permet toutes les toutes
les gymnastiques François l'a dit
suppression des cycles et cetera et
cetera suppression des progressions et
au bout du compte des de des évaluations
bon et ça veut dire examen en l'étard
n'est-ce pas qui sont avec les
monstruosités que vous savez
voilà un mot sur l'influence du
Parlement sur mon vécu parce qui me
frappe c'est et et ça fait écho à la
campagne de François et à l'idée qu'il
porte il y a dans le fonctionnement de
nos
institutions un un fait qui n'est pas
écrit mais qui est très puissant qui est
le fait
majoritaire ce qui fait que ça rend le
parlementaire dans leum met dans une
situation intenable c'est-à-dire que le
texte qui est généralement d'origine
gouvernementale euh soit il est adopté
parlementaire par les parlementaires de
la majorité si il ne vote pas tel que
cela leur a demandé ce sont déjà des
traîtres le fait même qu'il puisse
connaître la matière et ne pas partager
la vie du gouvernement et le début de la
trahison et moi ce que j'ai beaucoup
aimé dans la campagne de François et qui
m'a vraiment convaincu après avoir vécu
tant d'années dans cette situation
c'était que il n'est pas vrai que nous
pouvons durablement vivre dans un monde
où tout est ou blanc ou tout est tout
noir il faut permettre à chaque personne
qui est représentante d'un territoire de
pouvoir donner son avis et il faut
veiller à ce que subsiste des majorités
pour gouverner néanmoins je termine sur
ce qu'a dit François tout à l'heure et
sur une des questions
sans être désagréable mais je n'avais
pas osé dans un premier temps donc je
vais le faire maintenant s'agissant du
recrutement pour la haute fonction
publique
elle est la haute fonction publique
composée aujourd'hui à partir de
concours où le bachotage propre à la
matière administrative est de plus en
plus développé et il est capital pour
pouvoir réussir le
concours mais de sorte que ceux qui
réussissent le concours peuvent être
cultivés mais c'est n'est pas
complètement indispensable c'est pas
requis voilà parce que c'est parce qu'on
va leur demander pour pouvoir réussir au
concours donc méfions-nous méfions-nous
parce que les têtes sont très très bien
faites la question n'est pas là en tout
cas bien pleine sontelles bien fait
c'est une autre affaire en tout cas pas
toujours et
la ce qui celui qui vous le dit le dit
avec beaucoup d'humilité parce que moi
je ne suis pas cultivé je disais dans la
voiture il y a aucune flacanderie
les gens C TV dans la politique sont
rares je parlais de de la période même
si je disais aux jeunes stagère qui
m'accompagnait que c'était un filou
Edgar fort par exemple était d'une
culture absolument immense et je pense
que dans la
génération aujourd'hui ça manque un
peu
féminin
il nous reste 8
minutes moi je souhaitais revenir un
instant à ce que vous avez exposé d'une
manière brillante et qui m'a totalement
séduite par la clarté du propos et par
la clarté des contenus donc sur la forme
et sur le fond et c'est je pense qui
fait l'intérêt de la loi qu'il y ait
justement une correspondance entre la
forme et le fond et ce qui fait
l'efficacité de la loi c'est qu'il y ait
une correspondance entre cette forme qu'
loi et le fonctionnement de fond de la
société dont il est issu et à laquelle
il va s'appliquer il me semble que dans
cette
enceinte centr triste je trouve qu'il
est un peu dommage de se poser la
question entre
garder
une tradition une structure du droit et
des institution à la française et de
continuer à l'opposer à une culture une
tradition une pratique
anglosaxonne parce que dans le l'esprit
de la loi tel que vous l'avez vous-même
défini le comm la la jurisprudence ça
existe donc les deux ne sont pas
exclusives l'une de l'autre enantoche
qu' soit de fait dans l'histoire qu'elle
est été dans l'histoire de T ou t autre
pays n'en fait pas des conceptions
exclusives l'une de l'autre
pour toujours à jamais et une chose qui
me paraît fondamentale parce que ça n'a
pas été évoqué du tout c'est qu'on est
déjà un plein dans une juridiciation je
sais plus le terme
exact une une donc des comportement
procéduriers on va dire mais aussi de ce
qu'on a appelé de nos vœux en France
longtemps à savoir des mouvements
associatifs de revendication mais qui
vont en procédure on y a déjà de fait et
qu'ensuite les procès il se gagne aussi
dans un rapport de force même si on n'
pas un cadre légal qui est celui de la
common law que le développement
d'Internet quand vous allez regarder sur
internet parce que vous vous posez une
question quelconque de comment dois-je
faire pour être dans les règles de droit
ou alors est-ce justifié que je sois
attaqué qu' me reproche de ne pas l'être
allons donc voir puisqueeffectivement
personne ne peut inurgiter et retenir
par cœur des volumes tel que vous les
avez montré parce que ça ne concerne pas
que le droit du travail ça concerne
aussi tout le reste mais vous tombez sur
une myiade de blogs avec une partie de
réponse ou de suggestions qui sont plus
ou moins correctes par rapport au texte
une partie qui ne le sont pas et qui
vont encore ajouter à la
conflictualité mais voilà là je m'arrête
là mais moi il me semble que c'est un
point fondamental et qu'ici dans une
enceinte je me répète centre où on
narrête pas de se dire qu'il faut
arrêter justement de poser toujours les
choses en terme d'opposition gauche ou
droite pour moi c'est pas le droit
français et la comm c'est le droit
réduit à son essentiel hiérarchisé comme
vous l'avez très bien dit et la
jurisprudence qui vient trancher dans la
multitude de cas qu'aucune loi ne pourra
jamais
prévoir contenu de la qualité de votre
question j'y réponds immédiatement sans
attendre la question
masculine mais c'est alternativement
masculin et féminin il y a pas
deck
je croyais avoir pris la précaution de
ne pas opposer les deux notamment sur la
question de Mademoiselle ou deès cette
très belle jeune femme qui est là-haut
elle est très jeune euh une ça ne te
suffit pas parce que non à mon âge on se
vante quand on est plus jeune on se
cache euh je neppose pas je vais même
vous dire que mon intuition et que nos
raisonnements même continentaux
sont un peu limit parce que nous vivons
dans un monde qui se globalise parce que
la technologie euh nous y conduit que
elle efface toutes les distances et que
euh le monde virtuel n'est pas le monde
réel il ne s'agit pas de vouloir tout
transposer mais il demeure qu'il va
falloir nous habituer à une
hybridation euh de nos vies et donc une
hybridation des du droit qui accompagne
nos vies vous voyez qui dirige pas nos
vies mais qui accompagne nos vies donc
je n'oppose pas les deux et j'ai dans le
notariat qui a à mon avis à tort lutté
bien trop contre le droit de common law
mais il avait en face des gens qui
avaient des bataillons entiers qui
combataient qu'il combattaent aussi j'ai
souvent dit que moi je je voyais à terme
une bonne hybridation afin de tirer le
meilleur parti de chacun des systèmes
mais mon idée c'est que plus vous
globalisez plus il faut donner de
liberté
et donner des cela étant une régulation
très très très forte au niveau de de la
globalisation et en revanche une grande
subsidiarité moi je pense que si les
continentaux veulent garder leur système
juridique il y a pas de raison de leur
en imposer un autre si les Anglo-Saxons
veulent garder leur système juridique il
y a pas de raison de leur en imposer un
autre en revanche ce qui fait la
spécificité de notre ouverture sur le
monde sur dans l'Europe et cetera c'est
d'être capable de jeter des des
passerelles entre ces systèmes afin
qu'il se reconnaisse plutuellement comme
on dit enendroit et je pense que plutôt
que de vouloir unifier il vaut mieux
faire des reconnaissance mutuelle il
vaut mieux faire des hybridations mais
je je pense que si on ne veut pas perdre
l'attention de nos amis il vaudrait
mieux que nous continuions ensemble tous
les deux priv vous avez compris vous
avez compris de quoi il s'agissait mais
moi je veux simplement dire une
chose qui est illustrée par l'actualité
que nous
avons il y a pas seulement un problème
de norme il y a
aussi un problème de
juge je parle du juge administratif en
l'occurrence moi j'ai trois expériences
intéressantes et qui sont en train
d'être soulign dans leur caractère
exemplaire ou en tout cas fascinant par
le surgissement de lafferme
tapis je suis allé en
justice devant le tribunal administratif
je à titre
personnel sur deux
sujets le premier était est-ce que on a
le droit
de demander un arbitrage sur cette
affaire il y a une règle du
droit publ en France qui est absolu
c'est que l'État n'a pas droit à
l'arbitrage l'État et ses démembrement
c'est représentation n'ont pas droit à
l'arbitrage on comprend pourquoi c'est
de l'argent public il faut que ça soit
un juge c'est pas des personnes privées
qui peuvent décider en s'entendant que
on va disposer de l'argent public c'est
une règle de droit absolue on m'a dit ah
non mais
Monsieur le CDR le le truc du crédit
liyonnais là c'est une personne privé
c'est une société privée c'est une
personne morale de droit privé c'est une
société je dis mais
attendez c'est le contribuable qui pe
jusqu'au dernier centime d'euros dit ça
fait rien la structure juridique
aujourd'hui
qui annonce qu'il va se porter parti
civile c'est l'état et
même pour que le CDR cette structure là
se porte parti civile il faut que l'État
lui enjoigne de se porter parti civile
première
démonstration je suis aller en justice
pour contester le fait que Madame
Lagarde le ministère de l'Éc
ne fasse pas de recours contre la
sentence jugée alors que on savait qu'il
y avait des problèmes sur les arbitres
des problèmes sur le jugement qui avait
été apporté et on a été débouté je suis
absolument
persuadé que les juges que j'avais en
face de moi savaient en leur fort
intérieur que j'avait évidemment raison
mais le juge
administratif dans la structure d'État
qui est la nôtre c'est un juge qui se
sent moins libre je suis allé en justice
devant le Conseil d'État sur la
privatisation des
autoroutes en disant on a le droit de
décider de privatiser les autoroutes
mais il y a en tout cas une loi c'est
que la privatisation en France elle doit
se faire par la loi et pas par un
décret et le Conseil d'État après avoir
délibéré 3 quand même a fini par
conclure que c'était ça mais pas tout à
fait et que donc c'était pas une
privatisation comme les autres et que
donc ça se faisait pas par la loi alors
je comprends le raisonnement juridique
mais vous voyez que avec des principes
absolument clair et
compréhensible normalement un
juge qui se sente et j'ai du respect
pour eux hein parce que c'est de très
grands juristes un juge qui se sentirait
pleinement indépendant il aurait dit
mais là il y a une atteinte à à ce que
nous avons écrit dans notre loi et donc
le l'indépendance de la
justice la séparation des
pouvoirs c'est aussi important que la
lettre de la loi parce que il peut y
avoir deux exemples que je viens de
citer la lettre de la loi connu de tout
le monde et que cependant le
jugement aille dans le sens des pu puant
ou en tout cas de l'État toutpuissant
c'est c'est c'est des c'est des bons
sujets de réflexion à mon avis et pardon
de d'avoir cité cet exemple on va
prendre la dernière
question il y en a plein choisis agès ça
c'est pas moi merci Monsieur de
Paris monsieur lbert j'adère tout à fait
à ce que vous avez dit lors de votre
exposé sauf un point celui en fait du
nombre du des gens mécontents vous
disiez effectivement que là l'inflation
des normes conduisait un nombre de plus
en plus grand de de mécomtents en France
alors ça j'adhère pas du tout parce que
je je je crois au contraire que
l'inflation des dormes et la complexité
en général sont de nature à je dirais
faire travailler de plus en plus de gens
sur le secteur non marchand et
d'ailleurs c'est c'est vérifié par les
faits puisque je crois qu'on a dépassé
le nombre d'emplois non marchand a
dépassé le nombre d'emplois marchands
ces derniers
mois et que tous ces gens-là finalement
n'ont aucun intérêt mais vraiment aucun
à ce qu'on supprime la complexité à ce
qu'on supprime les NES parce que
finalement on supprimerait leur emploi
au bout du compte
oui al et et ça va dans le sens de ce
qui se passe dans dans le financement
des emplois ce qu'on appelle les emplois
d'avenir j'ai été voir sur le site du
gouvernement il y a quelques jours pour
voir à quoi ça correspondit on en parle
beaucoup et on finalement cite assez le
le le creux de l'affaire le fond de
l'affaire les emplois d'avenir l'avenir
ce sont des
emplois administratifs
d'État ça finance pour une toute petite
partie l'innovation des entreprises
privées mais sous conditions mais le
gros de l'affaire ce sont des
emplois collectivité locale état
association voilà donc l'avenir semble
être là en tout cas la voie qui est
donné aujourd'hui semble être là
d'emplois de plus en plus associés à un
fonctionnement ou de collectivité locale
et et je crois pas du tout finalement
qu'on que que que tous ces gens qui sont
de plus en plus nombreux acceptent qu'on
supprime finalement le le bien fondé de
leur emploi alors ma question c'est vous
avez émis un vœux à la fin de votre
exposé qui était de de voir ce ce
mouvement s'inverser ve que je je
partage alors qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'il
y a dans le dans dans dans les dans les
projets concrets du MoDem par exemple
est-ce qu'il a en filigran des choses
très préc
qui vont dans le sens de ce
vœ sur je pas
répondre sur les principes
François d'abord clôturera
euh
sur sur ce que vous dites s'agissant de
savoir si les Français sont contents ou
pas je ne suis pas spécialiste des
études d'opinion vous avez un voisin qui
l'est je le laisse vous répondre vous
avez raison en revanche de dire qu'un
Français sur 4 c'est le chiffre que j'ai
retenu et concerné par la complexité
bien que trois Français sur 4 cependant
ne s'en réjouissent pas bon
alors vous avez une enfin vous donnez le
sentiment de ne pas être inquiet pour
eux et bien moi je suis inquiet je vais
vous dire parce que je ne suis pas sûr
que les salaires de la fonction publique
sont garantis et ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que les les pensions ne le sont
pas et que si euh les Français sont dans
l'idée
que la pension à laquelle il quand ils
sont des pensionn de la fonction
publique à laquelle ils croient leur
sera servi jusqu'à la fin de leur jour
je leur dis s'il nous écoutent par
Internet surtout prenez des précautions
parce que c'est pas vrai en tout cas
dans la trajectoire actuelle c'est de
moins en moins vrai donc je vous en
supplie n'y croyez pas ne croyez pas que
les salaires seront versés jusqu'à la
fin ne croyez pas que les pensions
seront versé jusqu'à la fin la compcité
tu elle tue et il faut le dire aux
Français elle tue leur
emploi moi je ne peux pas penser que
nous puissions parier sur la soutise de
d'un peuple il faut parier sur son
intelligence et après tout le miracle de
la politique c'est de rendre chacun
intelligent c'est pour ça que je suis
avec vous au modem ce soir et je pense
que dire à chacun des
Français ne n'acceptez pas la condition
d'assister
parce que si vous restez dans la
condition
d'assister ce sont d'autres
qui feront votre destin et de la manière
dont ils s'y prennent celui-ci est
menacé et donc reprenez un petit peu la
main et quand je dis un petit peu
progressivement et vous avez des
formations politiques qui sont là pour
vous écouter pour vous entendre bravo
Jean-Pierre de faire vivre un lieu comme
celui-là sur des sujets si inras que ce
que nous avons traité ce soir moi je
suis profondément optimiste je vais vous
dire pourquoi c'est que les jeunes n'y
croi plus du tout à cette légende il y a
que les vieux comme moi qui croient ben
moi je suis je vais vous dire j'ai
quatre enfants ils sont tous partis j'ai
neu petits enfants qui sont partout dans
le monde et il y en a aucun qui veut
revenir donc ce que je constate c'est
que croyez-moi la jeune génération va se
réveiller et elle va nous mettre en
maison de retraite et elle aura
raison merci à Alain Lambert de l'acuité
de son analyse et de l'amitié qu'il nous
a fait à venir exposer ses son jugement
je vous rappelle le samedi 22 juin
pour notre forum pour le renouveau
européen et nous nous retrouvons le 18
juin comme Jean-Pierre rillou vous l'a
indiqué autour de la jeune philosophe de
la jeune femme philosophe qui va nous
parler en effet d'éthique et de
bioéthique merci à tous et merci à Alain
Lambert